>>> WE HAVE SAD, BREAKING NEWS
NOW.
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT HAS DIED AT
THE AGE OF 84.
SHE'S REMEMBERED BY MANY FOR THE
UNIQUE PINS AND BROACHES SHE
WOULD WEAR TO SEND SUBTLE
MESSAGES TO WORLD LEADERS.
CNN'S RICHARD ROTH LOOKS AT HER
LEGACY.
>> AS A DIPLOMAT WHERE TRACT AND
TREADING GINGERLY ON CONTENTIOUS
ISSUES ARE THE NORM, SHE WAS
NEVER ONE TO MINCE WORDS.
>> THIS IS NOT CAHONES.
THIS IS COWARD ESZ.
>> HER COLORFUL LANGUAGE OR
STRIDENT ASSESSMENT OF THE
LEADER OF IRAQ.
>> I DON'T THINK THE WORLD HAS
SEEN EXCEPT MAYBE SINCE HITLER,
SOMEBODY WHO IS QUITE AS EVIL AS
SADDAM HUSSEIN.
>> HE SAID SAID TO BE SO
INCENSED HE PUBLISHED A POEM IN
IRAQI NEWSPAPERS CALLING HER AN
UNRELENT
UNRELENTING SERPENT.
FROM THAT MOMENT FORWARD, SHE
WORE A BROACH IN THE SHAPE OF A
SERPENT AND USED HER PIN TO SEND
SUBTLE MESSAGES WITHOUT UTTERING
A WORD.
BORN TO A CHZECHOSLOVAKIAN
DIPLOMAT, SHE AND HER FAMILY
FLED AFTER THE NAZI INVASION IN
1939 AND FOUND SAFE HAVEN IN THE
UNITED STATES IN 1948.
SHE BECAME A U.S. CITIZEN,
MARRIED MEDIA TYCOON JOSEPH
PATTERSON ALBRIGHT AND HAS
CHILDREN.
IN 1982, SHE TOOK A PRESTIGIOUS
POSITION AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY, BUT IT WAS THE SHOCK
OF HER HUSBAND ASKING FOR A
DIVORCE AROUND THAT SAME TIME
THAT CHANGED THE COURSE OF HER
LIFE.
>> THERE WAS AN IDENTITY CRISIS.
AS IT TURNS OUT, I THINK THOSE
NEXT TEN YEARS WERE THE ONES
THAT WERE THE MOST INFLUENTIAL.
>> SHE POURED HERSELF INTO HER
WORK, BECOMING FOREIGN POLICY
ADVISER TO THEN PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, BILL CLINTON, IN
1992.
CLINTON IN TURN TAPPED HER FOR
THE POST OF U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
THE UNITED NATIONS AFTER HE WON
THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE BECAME KNOWN FOR HER
TENACITY AND DETERMINATION TO
ELEVATE U.S. INTERESTS AT THE
U.N. THROUGH WHAT SHE CALLED
AGGRESSIVE MULTILATERALISM.
>> WE MUST SUMMON THE SPINE TO
DETER, THE SUPPORT TO ISOLATE
AND STRENGTH TO DEFEAT THOSE WHO
RUN OVER THE RIGHTS OF OTHERS.
>> SHE PUSHED HARD FOR U.S.
BOOTS ON THE GROUND IN THE
BALKANS.
THE U.S. ADMINISTRATION CHOSE
DIPLOMACY INSTEAD.
A DECISION THAT CAME AT A COSTLY
HUMAN PRICE.
AN EVEN BIGGER REGRET, THE
FAILURE OF THE U.S. TO INTERVENE
TO STOP THE RWANDAN GENOCIDE.
LESSONS LEARNED FROM HER PAST
AND THE PRESENT AS SHE CEMENTED
HER PLACE IN HISTORY BECOMING
THE FIRST EVER FEMALE U.S.
SECRETARY OF STATE OF STATE ON
JANUARY 23rd, 1997.
THE KOSOVO CONFLICT ERUPTED IN
1998, SHE LOBBIED FORCEFULLY FOR
INTERVENTION.
THE EFFORT HELPED THEM GAIN
INDEPENDENCE FROM SERBIAN
CONTROL AND THE SERBIAN
PRESIDENT WAS INDICTED FOR WAR
CRIMES.
>> NEVER AGAIN WILL THERE BE
MASSACRES AND MASS RAIDS.
>> SHE FOUND THE AMERICAN DREAM
WAS OMNIPRESENT IN HER LIFE.
>> MY LIFE REFLECTS THE
TURBULENCE OF EUROPE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE CENTURY AND THE
TOLERANCE AND GENEROSITY OF
AMERICA THROUGHOUT IEXISTENCE.
>> HER SUPPORT OF HILLARY
CLINTON BACKFIRED.
>> THERE'S A SPECIAL PLACE IN
HELL FOR WOMEN WHO DON'T HELP
EACH OTHER.
>> SHE APOLOGIZED FOR THE TIMING
OF HER SO-CALLED MOMENT IN A NEW
YORK TIMES OP-ED AND SEIZED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR GENDER EQUALITY
BY SAYING MY HOPE IS THAT YOUNG
WOMEN WILL BUILD ON THE PROGRESS
WE HAVE MADE BUT THAT WILL
HAPPEN ONLY IF WOMEN HELP ONE
ANOTHER AND FOR THOSE WHO DO
THAT, THERE WILL BE ALWAYS BE A
SPECIAL PLACE